he is the Democratic senator from Rhode
Island on our show an author of captured
the corporate infiltration of American
democracy now in paperback Sheldon
Whitehouse why aren't you running for
president what what's wrong with you
slogan is so easy what White House right
put one in there no you don't they say
every senator looks in the mirror and
sees the president
yeah we've really we're not suffering
from a shortage of candidate no we are
not okay well I want to get into that I
mean you are someone who I think is good
because you do criticize your own party
and I think they need a lot of criticism
for example the 2009 bipartisan I think
it was climate bill right yeah you think
the Democrats could have gotten that
done yeah so what happened was through
the house
god bless Nancy Pelosi for getting it
done it cost a few Democratic members of
Congress their jobs to do it but they
did it came over to the Senate and we
never took up anything why you can do a
just in practically empty bill to get it
into conference and then work on
something I think there was conflict
fatigue at the White House from
Obamacare yep from fighting that and
they just didn't want to have another
fight as a what about nano person in the
White House said Sheldon we just don't
want to take on any fights we're not
sure we can win really and you don't
think that's the right philosophy no I
kind of don't that leaves most of the
good fights on the table and what about
now is there a cuz I mean the news about
climate is just horrible now we have I
think a real opportunity but you got to
think about it in terms of a jailbreak
you've got 10 or 12 Republican senators
who want out who want to do a climate
bill and on the other side of the wire
you've got to get away car that most
people accept which is a big price on
carbon that's revenue neutral and border
adjustable but between them and that is
barbed wire
towers searchlights attack dogs all
maintained by the fossil fuel industry
literally literally and the attack dog
funded by well no I'd only the fossil
fuel that's what I was at that's good to
know but there's a lot of fear about who
might be the one to take the run for the
wire and get wiped out Bob Inglis in
Congress was legendarily wiped out by
them yeah so the trick is how do you
find a way for these ten or twelve
Republican senators to get there and
that means knocking back the crooked
rough effort that the fossil fuel
industry continues to do by the way if
you have heard they're the big oil CEO
say they support a price on carbon they
are not telling you the truth their
whole apparatus is still dedicated to
stopping it and if you look at the rest
of Corporate America they're doing
essentially nothing to push back on what
the fossil fuel guys have done and in
many cases their trade associations are
actually our enemies so you have good
companies with good climate policies and
nifty websites who send trade
associations to Washington that say no
nothing on climate change I think a lot
of this is because of the dark money in
politics right I think it's virtually
entirely because of the dark money in
politics you turn on the light in the
kitchen and the cockroaches scuttle you
put the light on who's putting the money
these things and a lot of the companies
and big donors who are behind this they
don't want to be seen they're gonna hide
they're gonna scuttle for their exits I
mean that that heat wave they had in
Europe a few weeks ago which was
something they've never seen they don't
have air conditioning over there and
yeah and they smell bad enough in France
[Laughter]
I'm not going they smell bad and it's
hot but then that heat wave move moved
over Greece Greenland Greenland yeah
which is for sale yes
well it's not for sale what do you think
about do you think that's crazy
to buy to say I want to buy Greenland
not by his standards I mean there's so
many things he actually does wrong and
crazy I don't know why we have to be so
reflexive Harry Truman wanted to buy
Greenland in 1946 and we bought Alaska
in like 1857 they called it Seward's
folly but it wasn't really a folly was
it when the Louisiana Purchase yeah
right anyway Greenland Greenland is
melting yes 12 billion gallons a day of
water coming off that nice sheet at the
peak I heard they said it was melting at
a level that the models hadn't predicted
to happen until 2070 yeah so think of
yourself living in 2070 yeah and if we
reach that the sea levels would rise by
20 feet yeah which is my surgeon to get
after you dark money nonsense because
that is what is holding us back and as
Democrats that ought to be our daily
focus if you are playing a video game
and zombies were attacking you in the
video game and they were all powered by
the same power source right maybe a
lousy player all you did was fight the
zombies didn't attack the power source
so what about their power Thor
so what is your advice to the Democrats
I am tried week after week here I think
you know this yeah to kind of be their
coach saying things like go on Fox News
yeah you would agree with that
you got it where the people are okay
Rhode Island colleague David Cicilline
does a very good job going on Fox News
for the House Democrat okay good
stop apologizing for everything correct
you believe that you believe there's too
much purity testing yeah way too much
okay
so what a cooler firing squad we can't
we can't waste time fighting with each
other when we have the situation we face
now with this White House and when we
have the problem we have with the dark
money I mean in some respects Trump is
almost a distraction from the other
problem he's awful he's mm-hmm really
dazzling in his crudité and a lot of
attention goes to him in the meanwhile
here all these big special interest
spending unlimited amounts of money
yeah influence the Supreme Court to take
over the EPA to control Congress and
eliminate saloon some nice people I
think wonder why did why did so many you
know conservatives still like him well
he gives them a lot he give him a lot
that they want if that we want and he
scares them a lot yeah he does that look
at a couple of my colleagues that like
bob Corker yeah sure deflate no he
basically he's an Intimidator you put
him out so I've long said that one of
the structural reasons why the Democrats
have such an uphill battle is because we
have 40 million people here in
California and only two senators yeah
how many in your state
1 million 1 million and they get two
senators yeah if you personalize it for
a minute
yeah I don't have the numbers right now
but I remember giving a speech on the
Senate floor when I did have the numbers
there was a Republican majority in the
Senate and when you added up the number
of Americans that those Republican
senators represented right it was 40
million people fewer fewer than the
Democratic minority represented so yeah
we have a representation problem we've
had presidents who got elected without
having won the popular vote after red
map we had the House taken over after
losing the popular vote by a million and
we have the Senate with this baked in
problem the Republicans do a really
determined job of winning power with
fewer voters and we don't take on that
infrastructure and we don't take on that
strategy we're too happy fighting the
fight of the minute it's second-grade
soccer chasing the ball and they are
planning ahead well you get after them
please
you